France insoumise devrait se renommer,
se rebaptiser la France islamiste.
La France insoumise, comme la gauche NUPES,
représente aujourd'hui 1 danger,
1 danger pour les valeurs de la République,
1 danger pour la laïcité.
La la gauche aujourd'hui NUPES a épousé
les thèses des islamistes,
c'est-ce que certains intellectuels ont appelé
l'islamo-gauchhisme
et visent en permanence à, à, à défendre. Euh,
les revendications politiques originales.
On a le sentiment que la gauche aujourd'hui
a tourné le dos à ses valeurs,
qu'elle a tourné le dos à la laïcité,
qu'elle a tourné le dos,
euh, à la République française,
qu'elle a tourné le dos à l'universalisme républicain.